last year the National Institutes of
Health halted a study of synthetic
estrogen after concluding that the risk
to postmenopausal women using the
hormone outweighed the benefits next
Barbara seaman explains the controversy
and her new book the greatest experiment
ever performed on women it's an hour in
ten minutes today we welcome you to our
noontime lecture series where authors
and journalists offer their insights on
the important issues of our time we're
fortunate very fortunate to have Barbara
seaman with us today to discuss her new
book the greatest experiment ever
performed on women exploding the
estrogen myth Barbara is no stranger to
the controversies of women's health care
a women's health advocate for more than
40 years Barbara seaman was the first to
reveal that women lacked the information
needed to make informed decisions on
contraception and childbirth her first
book the doctor's case against the pill
which was published in 1969 became the
basis for a US Senate hearing resulting
in the placement of a patient warning on
oral contraceptives which by the way was
the first on any prescription drug after
the publication of her second and third
books free and female and women and the
crisis in sex hormones she was cited by
the Library of Congress as the author
who raised sexism in health care as a
worldwide issue today is the co-founder
of National Women's Health Network a
woman's advocacy group in Washington DC
and as a frequent contributor to the New
York Times and The Washington Post
Barbara continues to ensure that women
have the information they need to make
informed decisions about their own
bodies and about our own health care the
greatest experiment ever performed on
women published earlier this month by
Hyperion is an important and current
expose on the women and the crisis in
sex hormones topic we will take
questions at the end of our talk and we
thank Barbara seaman for continuing the
work she does on behalf of women in
health care please welcome Barbara
seaman
thank you all so much for coming out in
this muggy unpleasant weather greetings
and welcome if you are a woman and I'm
happy to see there uh some men in the
audience you may have hormones on your
mind should you go on them should you go
off them you may be frightened not to
take them because you'll turn into a
Crone
or perhaps endure the living decay
described by dr. Robert Wilson in his
1966 drug company sponsored bestseller
feminine forever on the other hand you
may be frightened to take hormones
because they might give you cancer or
heart disease or severe memory loss and
dementia as a disc all the NIH announced
only last May that for women over 65 as
they take a crimp row they double their
chances of getting dementia it's a very
powerful increase so what happened to
Alzheimer's prevention for which many of
these women were actually taking it well
forget that sorry
too bad and that's just what the drug
companies have done through the 65 years
that the greatest experiment has been in
place the manufacturers aimed first on
this Alzheimer's claim and apologized
later
that's what they always do
wait until you read my chapter on the
flimsiness of the Alzheimer research
they asked patients with Alzheimer's if
they ever took estrogen the patient said
no the research is that oh boy look at
this the control group without the
Alzheimer's did take estrogen so the
estrogen must have protected their
brains but then came the reckoning less
gullible researchers cross-checked with
the pharmacy records and can you guess
what they found
what do you think they learned from the
pharmacy records but what happened
they forgot some of these Alzheimer's hi
some of these Alzheimer studies were
we're done by interviewing patients with
Alzheimer's to ask them what drugs they
had taken for the past 30 years so this
this explains what the quality of some
of the research should I get closer to
the microphone um it's a good example of
how the youth and longevity benefits
were foisted on us with studies that
were ludicrously and perhaps
deliberately flawed and my supposed to
look over there or just wherever once
you digest these methods once you learn
to separate the good study from the bad
the real from the Earth's ads you will
be in a position to make sounder and
safer decisions about your health and
your family's health and I hope that my
book will help you to do so because I
have spent 43 years discovering their
little promotional secrets and they're
all there and if you can understand them
you're much less likely to be fooled now
let me ask you are you considering
hormones because you are suffering or
are you looking for a fountain of youth
here is where the great divide exists
it is simple and it is sane those who
are swept away by menopause may decide
the risks are worth it to gain relief
but those who are looking for something
more may at best be wasting their money
there is so much confusion out there
among doctors among patients but not me
I'm not smarter it's only because I've
been on this hormone beat for the forty
three years since 1960 when the pill was
approved as a contraceptive I was at the
original press conferences and in the
1960s I got to interview the guys who
had discovered these compounds back in
the 1930s and I'm still here and I'm
still standing to tell the amazing story
of estrogen as I witnessed it and as I
saw it unfold write what you know my
mother was an English teacher and that
is what she told me and that is what I
have done in this book this is my
journey in the land of the false
estrogen claims last week the for 43
years I've been trying to get the
manufacturers and the doctors who Front
for them to justify themselves and I
want to make it clear that I think most
doctors are very well intentioned to
their toward their own patients and
maybe they were mistaken and pushing
long term hormone treatments but they
certainly meant no harm the problem is
that the drug companies have always
gotten prominent doctors who are very
well respected to speak for them to
prepare continuing medical education
programs for them to put their name on
articles that the drug company PR people
actually write and then place in the
medical journals I see that what if the
very well experienced and just English
journalists here is nodding her head she
knows about all this
it sounds it sounds almost hard to
believe for many people but if you've
been on this beat you know that it's
true
last week the San Francisco Chronicle
observed twice quote c---minus to sex
hormone manufacturers what rat terriers
are to tug toys I like it I'm just very
glad that they didn't say that I'm a
pussycat back to the hard decisions
Laureus a reader of my magazine calm
wrote to me last November quote at age
sixty plus I'm back to hot flashes my
hair is falling out and my wrinkles are
getting wrinkles from fro kept me sane
and well-preserved for almost 15 years
I went cold turkey now I feel that I
aged overnight in December I heard back
from Laurie quote I don't want to suffer
anymore I'm going back on hopefully one
day the scientists will be able to
separate the harmful properties of the
drug from the beneficial elements until
then I feel as if I'm eating a poisoned
Apple now this is very she writes well
it's a little bit amusing but this is
very sad because there are millions on
millions of American women going through
this back and forth now and very
tortured and very frightened and one of
the things that bothers me the most is
the way that alternatives are now being
put before them as if the alternatives
were known to be safe and they're not
known to be safe we don't know enough
about the mobile turn it is either and
as far as I'm concerned the worst
alternative is that a lot of women are
going back on estrogen alone because
they believe that it's the combination
and many doctors believe that the
combination of progestin and estrogen is
more dangerous than estrogen alone but
of course that's only two above the
waist you may get more blood cancer and
more heart attacks if you take the
company
more breast cancer but below the waist
the estrogen alone isn't much more
dangerous there's a extremely high rate
of endometrial cancer if you check
estrogen alone very high it's comparable
to thee to smoking and cigarette smoking
and lung cancer
most of the endometrial cancer that
women get seems to be connected with
taking unopposed estrogen and if you
stay on unopposed estrogen for 10 15 20
years your chances of getting into
michio cancer rise from about one to two
and a hundred to about one to five one
in five so it's a terrible thing to be
urging women to go back on unopposed
estrogen and I hope you'll ask anyone
who's thinking of doing it to look up
the cancer statistics to call the
American Cancer Society to look on the
FDA websites and so forth it's very very
dangerous I went on the hormone beat as
some of you know because my aunt died of
endometrial cancer in 1959 and her
doctors at Memorial Hospital told us
that her cancer was due to the premarin
and they told us not to take premarin
because we might have the same system
susceptibilities so i could never figure
out and i still haven't figured out why
they would casually give women menopause
treatment that could might kill some of
them that does kill some of them when
nobody ever died of menopause and I've
been wondering whether the game is
really worth a candle now what can we
learn from these observations that I've
quoted so far first the very fact that
we all think we must make an estrogen
decision see or know has nothing to do
with serious science it's a brilliant
promotional device a brain washer to the
contrary mysterious science has warned
us for 65 years
that while estrogens are highly
effective in treating severe power
surges formerly known as hot flashes
they carry dangers that are all too real
they can cause blood clots and they can
make cells divide and both of these
serious side effects have been known
since the 1930s but they've been hushed
up the blood clots contribute to the
heart attacks strokes and memory loss
dividing cells can bring on cancer there
was never serious science behind the
claims that estrogen could prolong a
woman's life that was unlikely
considering these two major drawbacks
that was hype that was wishful thinking
that was smoke and mirrors a Fountain of
Youth Mirage that was the triumph of
marketing over science it was only
through the wily persistence of the drug
companies fooling us into fearing that
menopause is a deficiency disease like
diabetes making up scary phrases like
when women outlive their ovaries that
was very popular in the 70s bombarding
us with hokey studies that I call
science by press release and a variety
of promotional tricks that are
thoroughly explained and documented in
my book the greatest experiment ever
performed on women I don't want anybody
to be snookered like this anymore
now I understand that we all have to
make a living I agree that everyone in
business has the right to show their
products in a favorable light but there
in mind as I've already mentioned nobody
ever died from menopause while thousands
of women have died from the consequence
of their menopause treatments hormone
products are not wallpaper
they shouldn't be hyping them or making
exaggerated claims
yes the other hand and concealing the
dark side was very very wrong however
there are many women for whom these
products used in the short run have
brought merciful relief when they were
suffering grievously and I've known many
women like that after world so let's
let's check out the math and the money
and see who's been taking estrogen and
what for and to what extent it's the
people who might really need it after
World War 2 an excellent protocol was
described by dr. Charles Dodds
consulting physician to King George in
England and an innovative biochemist he
was a British patriot who unwittingly
jump-started the greatest experiment
meaning the pervasive use of female
hormones without any caution or curbs or
prior research and to give you a taste
of the dramatic backstory here is what
happened in 1938 Dodds published his
formula for a synthetic estrogen in
nature magazine it was an estrogen that
was powerful cheap to manufacture and
effective by mouth up until then
estrogen products were given by
injection to give you a taste of the
dramatic up until then the estrogen
products were given by injection das
relinquished his own patent rights
because he wanted to stop the Germans
and Hitler from cornering the world
market on sex hormones it's a very
dramatic and fascinating story the man
who worked for the shearing company in
Germany the biochemist were for shearing
and whose name was on the patent Hans
her loft in Hoffman had actually come to
England under the pretense of being an
independent scientist who wanted to
study with Dodds and he worked in his
lab for a year he never told him that he
was actually an employee of cheering so
Dodds
the conclusion that in hoffman was the
spy that next he was going to go steal
the the Estridge then he jaws had been
working on and so he decided to give
away his his own formula to the world
and he published it in nature magazine
he das could have become a very wealthy
man he could have made millions and
millions of dollars from this patent but
his patriotism overrode his love of the
good life and and I knew him he was one
of my favorite mentors and and he did
like the do good life he was the the son
of a shoe salesman the retail shoe
salesman and he was very proud of his
rolls-royce royce and he loved good
wines but he gave away this patent in
order to stop Hitler as possible
cornering of the world hormone supply
well within a year now unfortunately do
any of you know what Charlie does is
estrogen was what the name of it was
well get ready for some very bad news
have any of you heard about the des
babies
it was des poor charlie he died a very
sad and tortured man because he did
everything he could to try to stop those
experiments he called he talked about
the crazy people in America I have a
chapter chapter five and in the greatest
experiment is called the crazy people in
America and he was referring to the
scientists and doctors in America who
had dreamed up the idea that they could
use diethylstilbestrol
diethylstilbestrol thanks Judy to to
grow bigger and better babies and to
prevent miscarriages it was insane but
Charlie was unable to stop it and the
lead man in all this was dr. George von
sieglin Smith who was head of the
gynecology Department and nothing less
than
at medical school so Charlie Dodds
opened Pandora's box he let the genie
out of the bottle
within a year thousands of doctors and
scores of drug companies were using his
estrogen for any purpose they could
think up
no wonder Dodds we referred to these
crazy people in America because most of
the activity was happening here where
there were 12 different drug companies
who were manufacturing estrogen products
within a few months of his publication
in nature magazine now choi das was very
worried about cancer and he had a good
reason he noticed that the men in his
laboratory who in those days wore
suspenders that when they handled the
estrogen dust or the powder they would
their suspenders would billow out in
other words they were growing breasts so
that was a very bad signal to him he
said yes he sent samples around to
several of the Cancer Research as he
admired the most and indeed they all can
they all found that it did that the DES
and other estrogens the German estrogen
also that the ethanol estradiol whatever
estrogens they tried they tended to make
the cells divide and and create cancers
in the small laboratory animals and they
also found that when they gave it to
pregnant rats and mice the pups had
exactly the same intersexual problems
that the des daughters and son sons had
were discovered to have 30 years later
so all this was known now in the middle
of this the cat went as as these 12
American firms were honing in on the FDA
and doing all the things they do to get
their thing approved you know
identifying the officers at the FDA who
might be sympathetic and who might be
looking for revolving door jobs highly
paid jobs with the drug industry once
they had done the favors that were being
asked of them I think you probably all
have heard about this it's very common
even today so the cancer researchers got
word that there was a big effort to get
the FDA to approve estrogen and most
many of them just did their best to stop
it it was very sad one of the do you all
know who dr. George Pappa Nikolai was
you know what he did right the pap smear
he was one of the greatest scientists in
the area of cancer prevention when he
heard about these companies he rounded
up the whole Council of farming
pharmaceuticals at JAMA and they put
together a whole issue with various
articles begging American doctors to
stop using it until much more was known
and he published a plea against it in
the in JAMA which said because the
product is so this is the quote from dr.
Papanicolaou in 1939 because the
products are so potent and because the
possible harm must be acknowledged we
are of the opinion that it should not be
recognized for general use of the
present time however despite all the
efforts of these knowledgeable cancer
doctors in September 1941 September 19th
which is my sister's birthday this was
two months before Pearl Harbor the FDA
approved estrogen for the treatment of
menopause complaints now among the
companies of the 12 companies in this
consortium one of them was Ayres
Laboratories a small firm in Canada that
was working with horse urine premarin
which stands for pregnant mares urine
and the by the way the doctors the
pharmacist thought that the name was
very funny they thought they'd come up
with a genius name pregnant mares urine
premarin so it would signal to them what
it stood for but of course the patients
didn't know very few patients knew what
they were taking and many of them were a
little disturbed when they found out but
in any case the very charming man named
Bill McKenna who was a vice president of
Erised and very he could get anyone to
do what what he wanted he had this he
was one of these salesmen with his
enormous whatever just a few months
afterward and may 1942 he got the
premarin approved by the FDA and this is
completely contrary to what most people
think if I hadn't just told you this is
there anybody here who would have known
that it was available in the United
States by the beginning of World War two
is there one person who know that how
about you well there you go and one of
the reasons they've kept that hushed up
is that there's really no excuse for the
fact that they didn't do some good
research until the 1990s I mean it had
been going on for over half a century
and they were still making vigorous
claims for things which they had never
really tested in any kind of serious
trial so the FDA approval here's the
primary big problem that we had in this
country and still have the FDA approval
was mainly to treat menopause complaints
it was not initially to grow bigger and
better babies or as a youth pill or
anything like that but in this country a
licensed doctor can take any licensed
drug and he or she can write a
prescription for what's called off-label
use so once it was approved for severe
mental
as complaints the doctor started using
it for anything else that they wanted
and there's a very interesting history
on the discovery that perhaps the
estrogens could prevent bone loss in
women going through menopause if that
was the claim that was not really proven
until quite recently and it is true that
it does help prevent bone loss however
there's a little kicker to that and this
typifies the kind of science by press
release that the the drug manufacturers
constantly used in 1982 a dr. Harry
Janet who was a brilliant radiologist
did a very good randomized clinical
trial it was small but it was very very
good he had learned how to do very
exquisite studies of bone mass and what
was going on how much is being lost how
much was being retained so he took three
groups of women he put some of them on
relatively high dose estrogens he put
another group on low dose estrogens and
he put the third group on a placebo and
he reported that the group on the high
dose estrogens retained their bone mass
much more successfully than the other
groups he also reported that all of the
volunteers in his clinical trial for
women who had been castrated they were
women who had had their ovaries removed
they had had what are called radical
hysterectomies and they had had them
before they had reached menopause they
were still in their 20s and 30s or early
40s now when you take a woman who is pre
menopausal and do a radical hysterectomy
she is going to be thrown into a very
harsh menopause and she's going to
suffer a lot and she's going not
everyone but a great many do
and she's going to have a rapid loss of
bone mass so this is a special situation
where if it were me or my sister or my
daughter I think if somebody's going to
have to have her ovaries removed when
she's pre menopausal there's a very good
reason to consider taking estrogen
products for the time being at least but
the fact that this was done on a very
special group of women was never
publicized to women and in fact I don't
think the average prescribing doctor
unless he was a really active academic
type who liked to go back and look at
the details in obscure but important
scientific papers which most doctors
don't really have the time to do people
thought that this applied to women going
through natural menopause where there is
not very often nearly the same kind of
precipitous bone loss
so again women were snookered they were
led to feel and their doctors most of
whom again are were perfectly
well-intentioned that they needed to go
on estrogen at the time of menopause to
forestall what could be a really
debilitating amount of bone loss that
could lead to serious hip fractures and
even the possibility of death now
there's there's an interesting age thing
there because people at the Institute on
Aging some of them have been saying
recently that they think it's
particularly dangerous to give estrogen
at a time when the woman is actually
going through menopause I mean unless
you desperately needs it because she's
so uncomfortable because your hormones
are bouncing around so much anyway that
in terms of stimulating breast cancer
the risks may be higher if you add the
synthetic hormones to the hormone chaos
is going on in your own body so the fact
is that the deaths from
hip fracture most of what you're
associated with
the failure to practice good for fall
prevention much more so than just the
having the bones crumble but nonetheless
to the extent that fragile bones do make
a contribution to these hip fractures
most of them take place the fatal ones
start taking place when women get into
their late 70s 80s and into their 90's
so to increase the woman's risk of
breast cancer when she's in her 40s and
50s in order to possibly reduce the
risks of having a serious hip fracture
in her 80s and 90s that doesn't really
make a lot of sense to me I don't know
how the rest of you feel about it but
once again we were not told the benefits
and risks and how you would weigh off
one thing against the other finally I
would like to tell you I would like to
explain why we should only trust
randomized clinical trials with Percy
Bose and even then as my story about dr.
Gennady and the bone loss and they
removed ovaries goes even then you have
to know exactly who the group was that
that was in this clinical trial and you
have to know all the details to be sure
that they aren't leaving out some
information because if they are again
that's science by press release they're
taking a good study but presenting it in
a way that it seems to be saying
something else anyhow
you may know this but perhaps some of
you don't I just want to say it once and
for all because I think it's a very
helpful thing for everyone to bear in
mind there were many observational
studies that showed that women who take
estrogen definitely do have fewer heart
attacks than women who don't take
estrogen and they live longer and they
are healthier
and some of these studies that show this
with very prestigious studies such as
the Harvard nurses study which included
I think more than a hundred thousand
women very large number of women so a
lot of people believe this I can't blame
the average doctor for taking this
seriously because it sounds so
impressive except that none of these
doctors must have taken the public
health courses that I took when I was in
advanced science writing fellow at
Columbia Journalism school because the
first thing I learned in public health
was that do you know what the greatest
predictor of a long life is some of you
must know what estrogen what No
well maybe maybe but in terms of things
that can be that are not in born let's
put it that way what that's that's very
important for not falling and so on yeah
no but it's overall what what did
somebody say a healthy life yes but what
goes with a healthy life stuff yeah all
right
income that they the greatest predictor
of a long healthy life as two factors
one is affluence and the other is
education the greatest predictor of an
early death is poverty and lack of
education so there you go there are a
lot of things that are part of the
lifestyle of an affluent well-educated
woman that could be mistaken for being
good for the heart
that could be mistaken for being good
for her longevity but are really just
things that go along with a lifestyle
now another example that may or may not
apply that I've heard people say that
they think it does is that wine drinkers
certain wise are claimed to be good for
the heart and help you to live longer
but you all know the old saying that I
have a champagne taste but a beer budget
I mean obviously when you're going to
compare beer drink reserve whiskey
drinkers with drinkers of nice fine
wines the the drinkers of the nice wine
wines are living a better life generally
and they have less stress so so this was
all a big mistake but the thing is that
I knew it and a lot of people knew it
and somehow we were hushed up from
discussing it I mean we didn't say for
sure that we knew that the estrogen
wasn't what was doing it but we did try
to keep saying but wait a minute look
these women are taller thinner they
exercise more they smoke less they they
dye it and when they started taking the
estrogens they have lower blood fats to
begin with before they ever went on the
estrogens and they are less likely to
have personal histories of conditions
that are high risk conditions for heart
attacks such as if you had a history of
blood clotting your doctor wouldn't put
you on estrogens if you had very high
blood pressure or diabetes your doctor
might not put you on estrogens so you
which doing a on one side you were
having these affluent well-educated
women who were taking very good care of
themselves and on the other side you had
people who many not that there aren't
many people who take care of themselves
who don't take estrogen but the balance
was you know that that most of the
estrogen takers were in this affluent
educated group so what was needed was a
real clinical trial and that's what the
Women's Health Initiative did at last
there was a level playing field where
the women were picked randomly and they
were given either a placebo or the real
drug and they didn't know and the
doctors didn't know and it's not as if
the richer more educated women were in
one group and and the women who were
less fortunate in those regards were in
the other group so I have to say that
the real heroes of the fair
that we're finally finding the truth I
think are the volunteers and the Women's
Health Initiative it's an amazing thing
that over a hundred thousand women were
willing to put their lives on the line
for this it was an amazing thing and I
think we should thank them but the
reason that this study was funded and
here's where the sexism comes in and
then I'll stop and take your questions
but I just want you to know about this
in 1990 Wyeth Erised
asked the FDA if they could have an
approval to market premarin to prevent
heart disease and women and the FDA
advisory committee said sure now the FDA
advisory committees more and more
consist of people who are kind of
hotshot specialists in in their fields
but they a lot of them are embedded with
the drug companies they're the ones who
were getting a lot of research monies
from the drug companies between eighteen
between 1985 and today the amount of
medical school research that's funded by
the drug companies has I don't know
what's quadrupled or something is there
anybody here knows it's it's a huge so
anyhow the people who were on the
advisory the FDA advisory committee said
sure there are all these observational
studies they look good but in fact no
heart preventive medicine for a man for
men had ever been approved by the FDA
without major clinical trials this was
true even with aspirin before aspirin
was approved as a heart preventive
twenty-two thousand men were in a
clinical trial it was an expensive trial
so the idea that women were not getting
the same kind of careful scrutiny before
they took powerful drugs bothered
feminists and it was particularly
bothered some of the feminists at the
NIH who were trying to get more clinical
trial
for women florence Hazeltine was one of
the people involved with kirstine and
then Bernadine Healy came along and and
there was quite and there was an effort
in Congress they were Congress women
like Pat Schroeder that were working on
this so while this was going on and the
FDA was hearing the request from Wyeth
to approve preparan for the protection
of heart disease various consumer groups
and on public health groups were invited
to testify and nobody much had very much
in the way of and rejections there were
some qualifications there was only one
group that took a real stand and charged
sexism and said what's sauce for the
goose is sauce for the gander and I
don't think the FDA should approve this
until there's been a real clinical trial
that person was Cynthia Pearson who was
then the program director she's now the
executive director of the National
Women's Health Network which is an
organization in Washington that I
co-founded in 1975 with four other women
and our Charter says that under no
circumstances will we ever take any
money from drug companies now most of
the Astro most of the grassroots patient
groups over the years have started to
take money from drug companies and as a
result although some of them have stayed
pretty pure most of them have gone what
I call astroturf from grassroots to
astroturf but Cindy was very clear she
point gave the example of the aspirin
and she said we at the National Women's
Health Network don't think you should do
this until we've done a clinical trial
well the the nonetheless the advisory
board voted to give why it's what they
wanted approval to market this to
prevent heart disease but at the FDA and
on the staff itself there were three FDA
officers who were very principled
very concerned they took what Cindy
Pierson said seriously you know they
went and did their homework they look
things up and indeed she was right she
wasn't exaggerating there wasn't a
single case where a product used by
males hadn't been subjected to a real
clinical trial and so they exercised a
pocket veto they just didn't go ahead
and and say okay you can start your
advertising now now this infuriated not
only Wyeth but also the advisory or
because it's very unusual for the staff
of the FDA to refuse complying with the
Advisory Board so Wyeth complained to
the Senate Committee on Aging the staff
members would call down to defend the
fact that they had been sitting on this
for about a year and a coveting them was
the Deputy Commissioner of the FDA named
Bruce Burlington who was a very
brilliant guy kind of a well he was a
very brilliant unusual guy who was
hoping to become commissioner eventually
well he made a brilliant speech
explaining to the Senators why the why
the trials some clinical trials and
women needed to be funded before the FDA
in good faith could approve what Wyeth
wanted them to do and the Senators was
so impressed that they went ahead and
funded the Women's Health Initiative
which had been sitting there but which
hadn't been able to get funding so
because of this little staff of
dedicated people at the FDA we finally
got the big clinical trials which showed
that the opposite of most of the claims
for longevity from taking hormones is
true and this is a little bit like this
story with Frankie Kelsey you know who
wouldn't approve the thalidomide these
are heroes they probably deserve a
Presidential Medal however I just want
to tell you that when Bruce Burlington
did not get appointed commissioner at
the point when he hoped he would he had
financial troubles he was paying alimony
he had I think five kids that he had to
educate and in 1998 or nine I got a
press release I opened my mail I got a
press release from Y of Erised meet our
new vice president dr. Bruce Burlington
has come to be our vice president for
compliance for worldwide compliance and
I realized then that the beat goes on
there's still a big revolving door
however it is now come about that it's
like a virgin bride the FDA employees
who have been toughest on the drug
industry rather than the ones who were
really nice and helpful the ones who've
been toughest are the ones that get the
highest price and the biggest lures to
go through that revolving door so in
that sense maybe the FDA has improved
over the years thank you
Barbara I have your book and I want to
say what's very important is not not
only the facts but you inspire women to
say no oh thank you I think that's so
important I have spent a lifetime saying
no to estrogen I've said no to and as
you know I had the big blowup with the
most famous woman doctor who was for my
accused of being a pusher for the
pharmaceutical industry who is she is
like no Florence Nightingale she but if
you say yes
she's been outed now you see as well she
has been outed on how she yeah yeah I
missed that I but I think that's so
important because women are intimidated
by doctors I had a doctor who said to me
you're tall and thin and you had a
hysterectomy you must go on estrogen
well I'm still standing tall I'll be 70
years old next next year she's bent over
I think it's important to note that we
need as your book points out our diets
need to be looked at our food supply
needs to be looked at there's estrogen
in a lot of
food and well thank you very much thank
you hi would you touch about the
question what they call natural hormones
which is really nothing to do with being
natural but rather that they take the
percentage of estrogen to progesterone
different types similar to the woman's
body instead of a horse's well I I'm
afraid to say anything about
alternatives
I do have an appendix in here of 50
pages where I try to explain I give
information about all the things being
used now as alternatives but the problem
is nothing has been studied as well as
it should be so I don't know whether
it's a good idea to jump from one thing
to another I personally love certain
herbs for example I love chamomile and I
and I love peppermint and I love
echinacea but I recently learned that
our herbal supply in this country it is
so unsupervised due to some legislation
that was passed in the early 90s that
half of the herbs that we buy in the in
the health food stores don't have the
contents that the label says they have
some of them had don't even have that
particular herb at all and others just
have all kinds of different dosages and
so on so we're in a very dangerous
situation right now until we can get
better standards set for hirable
products I think we have to be very
careful hi I was just wondering given
the fact that the research indicates
that estrogen is is harmful is there any
way of reopening the FDA hearings on the
drug to reevaluate whether it should
circulate in the marketplace oh wow well
that's quite a question I I think see
the problem is that for women with very
severe menopause complaints sometimes
it's the only thing that works but the
percentage
there are about 10 million women going
through menopause in the United States
every year about 12 to 15 percent say
that they're having a severe enough
menopause so that they really need some
strong medicine for it which would mean
that there would be about a million and
a half women a year in the United States
who could legitimately be on estrogen
for real medical reasons well at the
time that the halting of the prim Pro
trial was announced exactly a year ago
in June 2002 there were there were 20
million women on so that means that
eighteen and a half million of them were
probably taking it for spurious reasons
not all together now I want to tell you
one more thing in this context which is
that Charlie does who I thought was
brilliant and forgive him for the D he
has because he understood how estrogens
work better than anybody else who I ever
met he he at first he didn't think
anybody should get these synthetic
estrogens and unless there was something
wrong with their ovaries girls who were
born without ovaries women who'd had
their ovaries removed otherwise he
thought it was too dangerous but then he
realized that there were enough women
getting so much relief from their
blessed menopausal medicine that it it
would be all right to let them have it
if they were in the throes of a severe
discomfort but what he realized that
isn't discussed anymore in this country
is that estrogen has certain addictive
properties more for some people than for
others for some people it's very
addictive and that's why some of the
women who were well past menopause were
miserable when they had to go off it in
this past year so his protocol which was
practiced in Europe for a long time was
this the minute a woman has her symptoms
under control she should start tapering
off and tapering off very very very
slowly for a full year and by the end of
the full year she should be down to the
place where she could stop and what he
and the doctors who he worked with found
was that the great majority of women
were fine at that point
if they had that very slow taper now in
Europe there was a less less of a huge
jump in in female cancers and
reproductive cancers than there was here
probably because a great many of the
women who only stayed on the estrogen
for a year but in this country the idea
of getting women off a drug for after a
year when you could keep her on it for
20 or 30 or 40 years
it was just unthinkable so that's my
answer I don't know if I answered you in
the way you wanted but I wouldn't want I
wouldn't rush to take it away from the
people who just really need it and there
are some how about I read your book and
I have given it to my daughter and I
hope every woman who hears of your book
and listens to you will get this book I
want to speak briefly about how
difficult is to get information out your
book will probably not get the media
attention it should and most people will
never hear what they should hear and I
don't know how we can overcome that but
I have a hadn't experienced myself I'll
just read quickly this is an excerpt
from the journal in Journal of the
American Medical Association which has
printed the March 1st 2000 and it's
called white cults and war crimes it has
to do with the state encompassed at
Harvard Medical School's the
pharmaceutical schools the the whole
military one sentence this book shows in
great detail how the federal government
the military establishment the
pharmaceutical industry and institutions
of medical research worked during an
extended period to create biological
weapons and prepared them for use in war
now this happened on the Korean War the
Korean War was a biological war and now
if I was to write a book I would call it
the greatest experiment ever performed
on human beings because was done by the
same people who you talk about in your
book this was done during the Korean War
was done to human race and to human
and across the book can only be ordered
it can't you can't behind in the
bookstore it's in there but you have to
order it special this what's the title
of the book well it's called him the
United States and biological warfare by
secrets of the Cold War in Korea by two
military historians from Canada and
University yes yes Zoey groves as I have
had the honor of having a forthcoming
review from Sally groves yes Barbara as
you know women are a cooperative lot
we're not so competitive and when I get
together with my colleagues in the press
they know about your book and they're
going to be doing things about it
because we are all victims or potential
victims
we have daughters I have a stepdaughter
whom I stopped from taking this crap
and yes the president
it becomes a like a snowball the moment
you get someone in the press interested
someone else picks it up and someone
else picks it up so we've got it rolling
thank you yes I had a TI a mini-stroke
while I was on estrogen and I resigned
it for short term and as a matter of
fact you were the one who told me to
stop the estrogen before the because he
knew about the studies but my concern is
that there are side effects for low term
usage of estrogen as well as long term
and in your book I was just wondering if
the FDA didn't go into the what can
happen if you ran it for a year if I'm
if I when I went with it
I'm just curious can I still have a
reaction from it a year from now five
years from now or ten years from now but
in the program it just said what
happened to people when they were on it
but are there other things that can
happen I don't really know the answer
that but I do gather this is anecdotally
observational II so it's not scientific
most of the people who have I've known
who've had T IAS and got off it in time
did not progress to have strokes but in
a few cases once the blood clotting
mechanism is sort of started or the
changes in the blood density whatever it
is that's been going on due to the
hormones in in a few cases there does
seem to be some continuous need to stay
on blood thinners and so on so it for
people like that it's a it could be a
lifelong memory souvenir
to be long-term and short-term so if an
MD doesn't know I figured maybe you as a
scientist might know does anybody here
know anything about this topic well I'm
sure you'll figure out a way to do the
research and get to the right people who
who are investigating it this is Judy
platter who for many years was the art
researcher for the International
Reader's Digest and she's a excellent
researcher she can find the most obscure
drawing or painting any place in the
world so why not why not the reason I
barber was nice enough to put me in her
book because I was researching lore
theorems and I know there's a big suit
out against Prem Pro which brings me to
my other question people are calling me
and they're asking me we know that Prem
Pro is harmful but what other forms of
estrogen are equally is harmful or have
other studies been done or is it just
for Prem Pro and I don't know the answer
we don't know the answer yet nobody does
but but we do know as I mentioned before
that from the waist up it's more
dangerous when you combine the premarin
and the progestin from the waist down as
far as both the uterus and the ovaries
go the estrogen alone is more dangerous
so you know you could you got to pick
which part of your body you want to take
better care of you made light of in your
book but I think is very serious is you
you said there was some estrogen that
wasn't dissolving equally in water when
you were taking it and it could be more
harmful for some parts of the body oh
wow very interesting yes Prem premarin
first of all Wyatt the company that
makes the premarin products has had a
lot of manufacturing problems in the
last decade starting in the early 90s
they just had one manufacturing
problem after another both for their
over-the-counter products and for their
prescription products they had a vaccine
like they wherever there was a big
vaccine emergency about two or three
years ago that was because of a premarin
product that turned out to be not
working properly when the today's
contraceptive sponge was suddenly taken
off the market that was because it
turned out that they were being washed
in polluted water or something and with
and with premarin there has been a
constant since 1999 constant recalls
because of dissolution problems which
means that they don't dissolve at the
rate that they're supposed to and the
doctors who are embedded with with the
company who always speak out in defense
of premarin products one of them is dr.
Lobo it can be a very brilliant man but
he does write the primer and continuing
medical education things and so on if
these doctors say it's nothing to worry
about but yet the FDA keeps recalling it
there are millions and millions of
premarin pills out there that are in the
you can read about this in my book it's
a really quite weird that are in the
pipeline and that they haven't been able
to get back and what I have been told by
the people who are a little concerned
about it is that they doubt that this
does these dissolving problems would
kill anybody but because they don't
dissolve at the rate that they're
supposed to if they dissolve too quickly
you might get very uncomfortable you
might get nauseated or you might get
sore sore breasts and you know from just
having too high a dose all at once and
on the other hand if the dissolving is
too slow and you're taking it for severe
hot flashes you may start getting the
bad flashes again so I don't know that
it's an emergency situation but it says
something about this company which
sometimes strikes me as as like the gang
that couldn't shoot straight I mean if
they can't
remember they've been making premarin
since 1938
so you would think that by now they
would they would have known how to how
to get it to dissolve regular yeah going
into menopause very early at the age of
40 and had terrible symptoms for about a
year and within a day of taking hormones
I felt much better yeah now it's been
three years so with all of the public
negative publicity I want to go off even
though my doctor says since I'm so young
I should stay on so I've started to
taper off so I think my quest I have two
questions one if your opinion about
hormones is any different if someone
goes into menopause early yeah and the
other is if you could talk a little bit
more about tapering off because I've I'm
concerned if I should taper off both
progesterone and estradiol estradiol
uh-huh at the same pace or if I should
keep the progesterone at a higher level
well I think the general belief is that
you want to keep the ratio the same and
there are various ways to do the
tapering off some people like to skip
one day a week at first and then after a
month or two they take it out two days a
week and so on others like to cut pills
and have her or do things like I don't
know there I've heard all different
regimens there are a couple of doctors
who are specializing in tapering off I
can give you their names later but as
far as whether to stay on or not that's
that's the big dilemma for because
somebody who's had an early menopause
maybe does need just benefit from having
the bone mass retained I I don't know I
mean you have to think about this very
carefully my and I'm not a doctor but I
will say that if you take her off if you
wanted to try charlie dodges old
protocol and spend a whole year try to
taper off and if at the end of the year
you feel fine
I was wondering what your thoughts were
about Avista I think it's this erm
because I was I had abnormal cells in my
uterus and I can't take hormone
replacement therapy but I have
osteoporosis and I'm very young and I
can't take class next so that's doctor
who suggested so I didn't know if if
this might have some if you thought of
this they might have the same kind of
problems well I mean if you I I don't
know I don't know enough about Avista I
would suggest that you look at the
National Women's Health Network website
they keep track of a Vista and the
Avista studies and do you feel well on
it oh you don't think anything well let
me ask you are you sure you have
osteoporosis I mean who told you that
g'way ananka oncologist I have us two
best opinion my spine and osteoporosis
and my hip and I'm only 55 I don't know
it might have been because I was Sun
Provera for a while to treat the
abnormal self yeah I see women are
always they take one thing and then that
starts something going and then they
take something else then they have to
take a third drug to wipe out the
consequences in the second truck I would
suggest that you contact the National
Institute of aging there's a woman there
named dr. Selman is it Salman
well she's the in charge of osteoporosis
studies she's a PhD for the national
state of aging she has a lot of
information on all this I I would I
would trust her but I do want to say
that I think osteoporosis has been made
into a you know again that was part of
the entrapment of women into feeling
they have to go on something we don't
really know first of all the bone
densitometry equipment is not really
that good there are a lot of questions
about it even now and it used to be
terrible secondly
the bone density is like like
cholesterol used to be before we knew to
separate the good cholesterol and the
bad the LDLs and the HDLs bone density
bone density
bone density is only one part of your
bone strength the other part is the
characteristics of it how the quality
it's called the bone quality now when
you drop it a good piece of china on
your kitchen floor it's actually less
likely to break than if you drop some
cheap heavy pottery garden pottery and
the reason is that the cells the
internal cells in the good China are are
more closely knit I guess there's
something like that going on in our
bones and so bone density is by no means
the whole story because the bone quality
is - and we don't know how to measure it
so it's just a standin for the whole
thing
the way just measuring your total
cholesterol would be and finally there's
a big shift now on the part of the NIH
and the CDC to put more more attention
on fall prevention rather than making
your bones a little more dense there's a
lot of controversy oh I don't know and
there are a lot of people who think that
the whole bone density thing was a bit
of a fluke I have a long footnote in the
back of the greatest experiment ever
performed on women about an important
doctor and Medical School
Jean named William pie no not Pike but
it doesn't matter you'll even find it
it's it's like a two page footnote and
it tells it all about how the
osteoporosis campaign was accomplished
and put over on the American public PAC
William Peck is the man's name at
Washington University in st. Louis okay
Barbara we have time for just one more
comment before we ask you to
please join us out front where anyone
who wishes to go home with this very
important book will have it signed I
hope by our author our final question or
comment thank you talking mostly about
oral estrogen and I would like to speak
to topical estrogen which has been
prescribed for vaginal dryness and it's
been prescribed like a cream you know I
was prescribed 15 years ago and the
doctor never mentioned endometrial
cancer and he never mentioned any
problems with it and you had a little
regime and nobody checked I went through
three gynecologists afterwards they were
different in different places that I
lived and nobody they all prescribed her
just to Rieger it was nothing not a
problem
and as a matter of fact Jame Brody even
prescribes it now for vaginal dryness
unfortunately i ended up with
endometrial cancer and I'd had no
warnings about it fortunately I had a
doctor who finally was aware of
something she saw that there was
something the matter and I was analyzed
and I had an operation and I'm fine but
it was pure chance that this was caught
and it's a very very tricky little drug
and it's absorbed in the vagina which is
the closest to the endometrial area that
you can get topically and there it is
and you don't have to take a pill or
anything I said no to all pills but I
was using something that was really
extremely dangerous next to an organ
that was extremely vulnerable thank you
that's very important information we
think that the patches are going to be
safer we think that the creams are going
to be safer and we hear all this stuff
about the first liver pass and if you
avoid the first liver pass nothing bad
is going to happen again there's no
reason yet to think that it may be true
maybe someday they'll find out there is
a difference but I wouldn't count on it
Barbara seaman is co-founder of the
National Women's Health Network the
greatest experiment ever performed on
women is published by Hyperion on the
web at Hyperion Books com